[CREAKING]
BARBARA IMPERIALI: So what we
are going to talk about today,
and I'm going to do something
a little annoying, as usual,
I want to take you
somewhere here.
Yeah, sure, back to
carbon, that's fine.
But what I want to
show you is the sizes
of the molecular
players in translation
because we are going here now
from the smallest carbon atom.
And we spent the first four
lectures on amino acids,
nucleotides, sugars,
phospholipids.
But we're entering
new territory here,
and I'm just going to
do this in such a way
that it comes onto the screens.
What you can see
here is, in order
to make proteins like
hemoglobin and antibodies--
these are made up of amino
acids, the really tiny things
that are out of view right now--
we need large entities that are
made up of either nucleic acids
alone or nucleic
acids plus proteins.
And so the things that
will feature today
are the transfer RNAs
and the ribosome.
And I want you to look at the
size of this molecular machine.
This is we're getting
pretty large now.
We're needing to
use large machines
to make the smaller catalysts
that are essential in the cell.
And, just so sort of maybe
size doesn't seem so important,
but let's just go a
little bit further here.
And what to me is intriguing is
that the size of the ribosome
is pretty similar to the
size of the rhinovirus,
a little smaller than
the hepatitis virus,
but quite a bit smaller than
some of these other viruses.
So the ribosome organelle is
a large entity in the cell.
And, when you do look at
electron micrographs of cells,
you can see these dark dots,
which represent ribosomes.
They're big enough to see,
whereas the proteins themselves
are not big enough to see.
So that's what you're
destined for today.
All right, OK, so I've
started to place on this board
some of the molecular players,
the messenger RNA, the transfer
RNA, and the ribosomes,
which are made up
of ribosomal RNA plus protein.
And I want to just remind
you about the structure
of the mature messenger
RNA just for a minute
because, in the last
class, we talked
about a lot of manipulations
of that pre-messenger RNA,
the fresh thing out
of transcription.
And now I just
want to remind you
that the messenger is
single-stranded RNA, obviously.
It has a 5 prime cap, which
has got this funky 5 prime,
5 prime bridge that's
resistant to exonucleases.
Somewhere in that
sequence is a start codon.
It's something that says this
is the bit I want to translate.
Often, there's a lot of stuff
here that you don't translate.
It's part of what's known as
the ribosome binding site.
And there are many
features in this part
of the sequence that are very
important for translation.
They contribute to the
efficiency of translation.
Generically, we'd call it
the ribosome binding site,
but there are funny things
called Shine-Dalgarno sequences
and stuff.
Don't worry about any of that.
I just want you to appreciate
that, the mature transcript,
you don't translate
the whole thing.
A lot of this stuff is
structural, functional
for other reasons
that contribute
to the success of translation.
Once you see one of
these, the ribosome
mows its way through and
reads the nucleic acids
in the message.
So the message is being conveyed
over to the new machinery.
And then, when you hit
one of these three codons,
and we'll discuss these
properly when we get to them,
it's time to stop and
finish translating.
The other end the message
has a poly-adenine tail.
Remember that, once again,
is structural to protect
the ends of that transcript.
Even if some of the hundreds
of adenine nucleotides
are nibbled off, you
don't get into the part
of the gene that's
critical to be translated.
At a certain stage,
though, you might get in.
Exonucleases might
chew up enough.
And they may end up
chewing up your transcript,
but that probably suggests that
the messenger has been around
too long, and it's time for it
to retire to a better life, OK?
So remember the poly-A tail.
And this, once again, plays
other functional roles
with respect to being
recognized as a transcript
and being helped to
get out of the nucleus.
So this was really what
we talked about last week.
There's one more
feature in here.
I'm just going to
remind you that
the final mature
transcript has also
been through splicing
with removal of introns
and the pasting together of
exons, which is a wonderful way
to diversify transcripts
of translation
and give you much more proteins
than one gene can encode, OK?
And we talked about
that last time.
Great.
So the first thing we
have to think about here
is how do we go from four
bases to a language that
includes 20 letters, right?
Or it's better
really, more precise,
for me to call them nucleotides.
It's more precise
because the base just
represents the ring system
that's attached to the ribose.
Nucleotide means the whole
thing, including a phosphate.
So we go from four bases
to encoding 20 amino acids.
Now there are a few organisms--
and, in fact, we have one spare
one as well, selenocysteine.
There are a couple
of other amino acids
that might be designated as
the so-called 21st, 22nd amino
acid.
They're not found
globally in all organisms.
We have selenocysteine in
just very, very few proteins.
So it's something beyond
the list of 20 that you saw.
There are other
organisms, for example,
in archaea, these
guys who hang out
in bubbling hot
pots in Yellowstone,
for example, that have
another amino acid known
as pyrrolysine.
I'm going to mention that
a little bit later on,
but the ones you really
need to think about
are the ones we're encoding
in the global genetic code.
This is the ones that are
common to everybody, all right?
So, obviously, when you look
at the language of bases,
one base--
if the language translated
directly one base
to one amino acid, we could
only encode for amino acids.
So we know it's not one
base, one amino acid.
And I know, at this stage, you
know that it's three bases,
but let's just go through the
math or the original questions
that were sort of circulating.
Like how do we go from this
language to the other language?
If two bases encoded
each amino acid,
we could only encode
eight amino acids.
That's not enough still.
16 amino-- wait a minute.
16 amino acids,
sorry, I can never--
anyway, that's 4 to the 2.
It's pretty good if I
can't get 4 to the 2
up at the blackboard.
This would be 4 to
the 1 power and then--
so what that came
down to realizing
there were not enough.
That wouldn't be a
sufficient language
to encode the 20 amino acids.
So it's finally deduced
that three bases
encoded each amino acid.
That would give us 64 possible
words in the language that
needs to be translated.
That's a lot more than we need.
We only need 20 for the
encoded amino acids,
so 64 possibilities.
But what else do we
need in the language?
We need a few more
things anyway.
Yeah, up there.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I
don't [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
Oh, you weren't.
Up there.
AUDIENCE: You need to know
when to start and stop.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: So, exactly,
so here this isn't necessarily
one of the ones that
uniformly codes amino acid
through the sequence.
We need a precise
way to say start.
And, in fact, we need
a way to say stop.
And there are multiple three
letter words that say stop.
So it turns out that
the genetic code, which
forms the basis of
this entire concept,
has some features to it where
it does have some degeneracy.
But we'll go through
the degeneracy,
and we'll take a look
at the genetic code
because it will tell us
exactly how the three letter--
the words made of three
bases encode everything
we need for
translation, all right?
So let's just go back
and take a look at this.
So we've looked
at the messenger.
I've told you a little bit about
the tRNAs and the proteins.
But then we just sort
of give you a little bit
of the back history.
And, once the structure
of double-stranded DNA
was deduced,
really, everyone was
moving on to trying to
understand how that converted
to the translation to proteins.
And there were a lot of workers
deeply involved in this.
Crick and Brenner realized
it was three bases to code
for one amino acid, but
Khorana, Nirenberg, and Holley,
Khorana who was part of our
faculty for many, many years,
actually defined
that genetic code
and got all of the details.
Brenner and Crick started
to have the ideas,
but, really, the definition
by doing a process known
as cell-free translation where
they could very carefully add
components to understand how
the code, the genetic code,
was formulated where they
put in specific messenger
RNAs and amino
acids and transfer
RNAs and actually made
proteins from that.
So that's the work that
Khorana and others did.
And that was awarded them a
Nobel Prize for that work.
And then, later on, things
started to get-- you know,
these are decades of work
I want to point out to you.
The ribosomes were discovered.
That was a decade
later, the sort
of details of the structure,
but not the structure itself.
And it was really
exciting in the 2000s
when Ramakrishnan, Steitz, and
Yonath solved the structure
of the prokaryotic ribosome.
So each of these things has
taken a decade to happen,
but they are fundamental,
major, important things
that we can act on and move
forward to understand more.
All right, so let's move
to the transfer RNAs.
And I've flashed up this
slide a couple of times,
but I actually now have
the movie of the structure
of a transfer RNA.
So the transfer RNA is
a linear segment of RNA,
but it's folded up the
way ribonucleic acids are
with three, four stretches of
double strand coming together
and loops in between them.
And the one end, this
is the 3 prime end.
I always try to
draw it on the left
because, otherwise,
things get confusing.
It's much easier to sort of
see where everything ends up
if you put the long
arm on the 3 prime side
to the left of your picture.
And what I think
is cool, when you
look at the structure of RNA,
we think of messenger RNA
as being a sort of
rather floppy entity,
but it actually
really likes to form
short segments of double helix.
It just doesn't do well
with the really long
double-stranded structure
the same way that DNA does.
But this folded up
structure is very important.
And it was on the observation
of these folded structures
that the ribosome
hypothesis was formulated.
But the two things that you want
to remember about the ribosome
are that the 3
prime hydroxyl group
of the last ribose within
this ribosomal sequence
is where the amino acid
that's going to be loaded
into your protein is attached.
So that's one point.
And then there's another
landmark on this structure.
And that's what's called--
one of the loops
has a special name.
It's called the anticodon loop.
It comprises three
nucleotides that
are complementary to the
nucleotides in your messenger
sequence.
So this really is a decoder
because, at one end,
it's carrying an
amino acid, but it's
carrying the amino
acid that corresponds
to the code that's in the
messenger via that anticodon
loop.
So it's a large structure,
but don't mistake it
for being something
that's just sort
of amino acid and anticodon.
A lot goes on with the
rest of the structure.
It's a very important structure
in the mechanisms of protein
translation and synthesis.
OK, so here I've got to sum
that up with a couple more
of the ways that you would
see the transfer RNAs.
You might see it in
this globular form.
And I pointed out
the anticodon loop.
The place where the
amino acid gets linked
is also called
the acceptor stem.
And, up here, I show
you that linkage.
And you should-- yes?
AUDIENCE: I was
just going to ask,
I see how the anticodons
are specialized.
How does the 3 prime
end of the tRNA
know which protein is bound?
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Yeah, and,
in a moment, not quite yet,
I will show you
structures of tRNAs
bound to their
synthetases, which
are the enzymes that load them.
So there is specificity
throughout that whole thing.
It's not just
bystander stuffing.
It's really involved.
And it's a great
question, and I hope
you'll get an answer
that's reasonably satisfied
from the structure perspective.
And so, if you look up
here at the acceptor stem,
the amino acid is
joined by an ester bond
to the 3 prime end
of the transfer RNA,
but, hopefully, you
can see in here.
There's the carboxyl.
There's the amine.
And CHR designates
the amino acid
where R would be the side
chain of your amino acid.
So that's what that looks like
at that end of the transfer
RNA.
And, coming down to
the anticodon loop,
you're going to read the
messenger 5 prime to 3 prime.
And the anticodon
loop, when you draw
this in this
configuration, actually
shows you that
the anticodon loop
is antiparallel
to the codon loop
to make that good
hydrogen-bonding network.
So that's why I like to
be consistent in the way I
render this structure.
So the anticodon loop of the RNA
complements that triplet codon
in the messenger RNA, all right?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
What's between the G and T?
BARBARA IMPERIALI: What's
between the G and T?
Hold on.
I'm going to-- what's
between the G and the--
AUDIENCE: On the loop there.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: Over here?
AUDIENCE: No, above
that on the left.
BARBARA IMPERIALI: On the left.
Oh, this guy?
So cool you ask that.
So this guy is what's
known as a funny base.
It's actually-- that's
the symbol for it
that you've picked out.
And it's a base known
as pseudouridine.
And it turns out that
these unusual bases show up
in RNA sequences.
Pseudouridine has an
interesting structure
where the bond to
the ribose ring
is not a carbon-nitrogen
bond, but, rather,
a carbon-carbon bond.
And it's a bit more stable.
So, in RNA, there's some of
these other unusual bases.
And pseudouridine is the most
common of the unusual ones.
It can still
hydrogen bond, but it
tends to show up in these
sort of different loops
and turn-type places, OK?
Thanks for noticing that.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So do you get
the G in parentheses
on the yellow part [INAUDIBLE]?
BARBARA IMPERIALI: The G,
which is in parentheses,
designates that even
those sort of bulges
between the real loops
can vary in length.
So it could be more than one.
So that addresses-- comes
back to that other question.
But that stuff in
between has variables.
It has variable bulges and
variable shapes associated
with the synthetase enzymes
that I'll introduce in a minute
that it recognizes,
all great questions.
OK, all right, cool.
OK, so [HUMMING]
we've got all of that.
So now let's move ourselves
so we've looked at--
we know the messenger well.
We're starting to
understand the tRNAs.
What we need to
move on to now is
sort of the most important
part of the game, which
is really taking a look
at the genetic code.
So this table is but one
rendition of the genetic code.
Sometimes, you'll see it in
different shapes and sizes.
In a second, I'll show you
one of the other renditions.
But it is the absolute--
the sort of Rosetta
Stone for translating
messenger RNA to amino
acid sequence using codons.
So this sort of-- whoa.
Getting a little--
I love translation.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting a little bit
excited about translation.
OK, so there are a few
features of this genetic code.
Number one, you won't
have to remember it.
It would be foolish for
us to think you could,
but there are characteristics
about the genetic code that
are very important.
But, first of all, let
me sort of calibrate you.
This would be the first of the
three letters in the codon.
And, by the way,
the genetic code
gives you the
identities of what are
known as the codons,
which is how we designate
the triplet of nucleotides.
So you'll hear a lot about
codons and anticodons
of course.
So the way you read this table
is you read the first letter.
So all of these begin with
U. All of these begin with C
and so on.
Then you read the second letter,
and there's those designations.
So, if I'm going here, here,
it's going to be starting UU.
And then, within
each block, there
are the four alternatives
for the other four bases.
And then the third
one, basically,
just designates those.
So you can read, for each amino
acid, what three-letter codon
would correspond to it.
Some people quite like--
oops.
I got rid of it too fast.
Some people quite like
this other rendition
where the first of the three
letters is in the center.
So it's either G, U, A, or C.
Then the second one comes out.
It's in the brown circle.
And then the third one is the
third letter in the codon.
And then that tells you what
amino acid that corresponds to.
And we'll generally tend to
just stick with this one table
and stick with it.
So you might as well get used
to that particular table.
Now there's a couple of
characteristics in the table.
The first thing to notice
is that, within that table,
there is a codon to start.
And it's AUG.
And the one thing that's sort
of sent to drive you crazy
is that AUG codon equals start,
but it also equals methionine.
And, in bacteria, it equals a
modified version of methionine.
So, if the ribosome is
reading the messenger RNA,
it will look for the first one
of these and start reading.
But, once you find another
one of these further
into the sequence, it
will put in methionine.
Methionine is fairly rare.
There may only be one or
two more in the protein.
And I hate the illogic of
that, but, nevertheless, it
is the case.
In some organisms, you start
with different amino acids,
but the most common start
is the codon for methionine
is the start.
So what that means is that
every protein you translate
has a methionine at
one of the termini.
Which terminus would it be at?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
Yeah, OK, so that's
the details with methionine
and the start codon.
Then there are
several stop codons.
And I've shown you the
three of them there.
The stop codons tend
to be used variously.
Some are more predominant in
some organisms than other.
And some of them
respond differently
when the process of
stopping occurs, which
we'll talk about in a second.
But the next important thing to
notice about the genetic code
is that it's what's
called degenerate.
Now, when you call
something degenerate,
it seems like sort of a really
nasty thing to call them.
And it doesn't mean,
oh, it's so bad.
It's just a degenerate.
It just means it is
specific, but it's not--
wait a minute.
I've got the right wording
here because I always
get this sort of--
degenerate, ah,
it's not ambiguous.
It's degenerate.
That's the best thing.
But it's not ambiguous.
What this means
is there are all,
for several amino acids, more
than one codon that specify it.
And let's take a look
at some of the examples
of that degeneracy.
It's at its most
extreme with residues
such as leucine where there
are six codons that specify
leucine.
Alanine has four
different codons.
They all specify alanine.
Lysine has two codons.
And it's generally appreciated
that the residues that
have more codons tend to be the
more common in your messenger
RNAs, in your final protein
sequence, because you'll find,
in your protein,
a lot of leucines.
So we need a few more codons
to stack the deck in favor
of putting in more leucines.
But so it's ambiguous--
it's degenerate.
But, what I mean by
it's not ambiguous,
you know what it's
going to code for.
The other place where degenerate
codons can become important
is that there is
species specificity.
So I'm going to write that in
here and explain what I mean.
And what that means is that
some organisms might prefer
two or three of the
degenerate codons,
and others may prefer
a couple of the others.
And what that means,
once in the laboratory,
is it's really
annoying if we want
to express a protein in a really
convenient bacterial system
that we've taken from
a mammalian system.
Our codon mix may
not be the same.
And so there are
companies now that
actually will fix the
codons in a gene for you
to make them compatible
with a different organism
for expression.
So it has huge
practical implications
to be quite honest.
And it can be very
annoying in the laboratory.
OK, and then so codon usage
varies amongst organisms.
All right, so now, one
last thing, so we've
talked about the genetic code.
It's the code that's going to
be embedded within the messenger
RNA.
The last thing I want to do
is, basically, explain to you
one more time,
when you're looking
to read what your amino
acids that get put in
may be, you're going
to look at the codon.
And it will tell you
exactly the amino acid.
A long time ago, I
used to be confused
because I thought I should
be looking at the anticodon.
And I was trying to
translate everything,
and it was a real mess.
But it's the genetic
code in that box
that I just showed
you is written down
for maximum clarity
and ease of use.
So, whenever you see a
particular three-letter code
on the messenger,
you will then be
able to know what amino
acid it would code.
So this is kind of interesting.
It just reinforces to you that
the codon and the anticodon
are antiparallel.
And so what I want to do is,
basically, in this diagram,
you would be reading from the
5 prime to the 3 prime end,
as the transfer RNAs attach
to the messenger RNA.
And that would give you a
codon here that would be AUC.
If you'd written this
the wrong way round,
it would look like CUA.
So you really want to be
reading 5 prime to 3 prime
in the codon.
And then you can go to your
favorite genetic code map
and say this thing is
read 5 prime to 3 prime.
And the amino acid that gets
put in is isoleucine, OK?
So you'll need to be able
to do that quite readily.
All right, next
portion, those monster--
loading the amino acid.
OK, so, as I said, this is a
many building block, many parts
thing.
So we've got the transfer RNAs.
We know where we load
them onto the amino acids.
We know where we load the amino
acids onto the transfer RNA.
But we do not know
how that is done.
So I want to show you
briefly how that occurs.
So let me just start by
drawing transfer RNAs the way
I usually draw them in a
very sort of cartoon form.
And, to attach an amino acid to
the 3 prime end of the transfer
RNA, you have an
amino acid residue--
we're just going to go R here--
carboxylic acid, amine.
Actually, I'm going to draw them
in their appropriate charged
states.
And what I need to be
able to do is faithfully
fix this amino acid to the 3
prime OH of the transfer RNA.
And what we do is
we need adenosine
triphosphate to
activate this chemistry.
And then the OH at the 3 prime
end reacts with the amino acid.
So I'm just going to draw that.
I'm leaving out steps because,
otherwise, it's too many,
and you'll be cross with me.
So you attach through an
ester to the amino acid
from the 3 prime end
of these transfer RNA.
That's what's done.
The ATP makes this
chemistry feasible,
but there's one
more player here.
And that's the enzyme that
brings them all together,
which is known as an
aminoacyl-tRNA synthetase,
meaning it's an enzyme that
makes an aminoacyl-tRNA.
And it synthetases it.
So that's how its
name gets subtracted.
So, with reference to an earlier
question, what I'm showing
you here are
different synthetases
for different amino
acids that show you
that there's a recognition
not just for the amino acid
that's being
loaded, but, rather,
for the entire transfer RNA.
So some of these
look quite different.
The isoleucine one
interacts in one way.
The valine one is
a little different.
And the glutamine one
is different again.
So they vary in the way they
interact with the transfer
RNAs.
So the transfer
RNAs are specific
for the amino acid that
is loaded onto them,
but also for the synthetase
that does the loading.
That's how you get
the specificity.
Does that address your
question from earlier?
Hello?
OK.
That makes sense, right?
So they fall into a lot
of different families,
but they're quite
varied when you
look at specific interactions
between the synthetase
and the amino acid.
And, on those synthetases,
there will also
be specificity for
the amino acid side
chain of the amino
acid that gets loaded.
Now let's look at the
ribosome components
because they're the
last big monsters.
Ribosomes have a
small and a large--
that's the large
and a small subunit.
They are made up, as
I mentioned over here,
of RNA and protein, so
small and large subunits.
And I've shown them there
in two different colors.
The prokaryotic
ribosomes are pretty
different from the
eukaryotic ones.
There's a higher
proportion of RNA
in the prokaryotic ones than
the eukaryotic ones, which
is kind of interesting.
And these complexes
are so big, and they're
made up of so many
protein and RNA
strands, that we don't
so much measure them
by the number of
those components,
but, rather, by what's
known as their sedimentation
coefficient, which gives
us a sense of the weight
of the module or the complex.
So the small subunit--
oh, he's back [INAUDIBLE].
The small subunit would have a
30S sedimentation coefficient.
The S stands for Svedberg units.
It's how fast its sediments
in an ultra centrifuge.
And the large subunit would
have a 50S sedimentation
coefficient.
And those correspond to a
certain number of daltons.
If you see that S
term after a number,
that's what it's talking about.
It's talking about the
sedimentation coefficient,
which gives us a sense of
the size of the complex.
And, when you start to bring
all the pieces together now,
what we can see on this slide
is the messenger, the transfer
RNAs, and the ribosomal
all to scale in such a way
that it can really explain it.
So what I show you here is
the small and large subunit.
In orange-- well, that's
kind of a burnt orange--
is a sneaky little
bit of the messenger.
In yellow are the transfer RNAs.
And there's one
more unit on here
that I won't describe too much.
It's a protein factor that
helps all the processes occur.
Generally, it's thought to
help the loaded tRNA come
to the ribosome, get it in
place, and then go away.
So it's some of
these extra helper
proteins that are involved.
OK, so let's build
a protein because I
know it's the moment we've
all been waiting for,
and we're going to walk through
how those pieces come together.
It's a very clunky animation,
but I'm very proud of myself
because I did it myself.
So I'm just going to show
you how these things happen,
as you assemble a chunk
of polypeptide chain
from a messenger.
And so here's the messenger.
It's being read 5
prime to 3 prime.
What happens, first of all,
is that the small subunit
kind of floats along,
looking for the place that
would be the ribosome binding
site that I mentioned here,
and then sliding its way
to position the start
codon in the right place
to start the synthesis.
Once that happens,
the methionine
that's on its tRNA, the
start one, gets into place.
And, at the same time,
the large subunit,
completing the ribosome
complex, comes together.
So you now have large and
small ribosomal complexes
stuck onto that messenger,
ready to carry on.
And, in each case,
you're translocating
through the messenger RNA.
And, in each step,
you're bringing in a tRNA
that's loaded with an amino
acid where the anticodon
of the amino acid-- and I've
got those little letters shown
on the bottom here--
is complementary
to the codon that's
within the messenger RNA.
So we can start
building this protein.
AUG is that start codon.
Methionine is the
first amino acid.
And it's always
at the N-terminus.
Then there's another
amino acid comes in.
The codon was UUU, and that
corresponds to phenylalanine.
And then the next
thing that happens
is there's a movement such
that a new bond gets--
a new amide bond is formed
between the methionine
and the phenylalanine.
And that new bond
is an amide bond.
It's not any of the others.
So you're literally intercepting
this complex on the transfer
RNA with the amine
of a new amino acid.
That's how that comes together.
I'm not going to worry you too
much with the chemical details,
but a lot of them have
been illuminated by having
the structure of the ribosome.
And it shows you, in fact,
that it's not proteins that
are catalyzing that reaction.
It's nucleic acids.
So now I'm just going to move
you on through the synthesis,
in each case, building
that polypeptide chain
and then moving, translocating.
This guy leaves.
The ribosome moves along.
This was a good Saturday
afternoon's work.
We've got to use
up all those tRNAs.
It doesn't get interesting
until you get to the end.
So we're using them, but now
we come and hit a stop codon.
We have UAG.
So what happens here?
The whole process slows
down because you can either
load what's known as
a suppressor tRNA--
that's the one, the magenta
one, that went up there--
or a protein release factor
can come in and bind.
But, in either case, there's
no new amino acid to come in,
and translation
finishes and releases
the protein in
its complete form.
Now the reason I
want to differentiate
between the release
factor and an RNA that
has the complementary
stop codon is
because the RNAs that are
known as the suppressor RNAs
have now been
completely hijacked
to make an enhanced
genetic code where
we can load lots of
different amino acids using
the suppressor RNAs.
And, if anyone would like
to chat to me about this,
I'd love to because I think
it's a fascinating field,
but it's a bit
beyond the scope of.
OK, so this entire
process took the following
where you've got small and large
subunits, all the elongation
factors and initiation
and release.
And then, in each
case, the energy
is actually not provided by ATP.
It's provided by GTP.
But where ATP is important
is in loading the amino acids
onto the transfer RNAs.
This occurs at about a rate
of 20 amino acids per second,
meaning you're reading about
60 bases per second, which
is pretty consistent with
the rate of transcription,
not the rate of replication.
That's far faster.
OK, sometimes, when you're
making a lot of a protein,
you will see that ribosomes
line up on the messenger RNA.
And you'll have
many proteins being
made at once and at
different stages in the game.
And this is a lovely electron
micrograph that actually
shows this process in action.
And, when you have a lot of
ribosomes on one messenger,
we call them polysomes.
They have that name.
OK, good, all right, so
what I want to do now-- so
does everyone feel
good about how
you translate a messenger into
a protein and the various moving
parts?
You would always know the
amino acid structures,
have the genetic code.
Just be familiar with
reading it and making
sure you could pick out
which amino acid might
be incorporated in response
to which particular codon.
So, when proteins are
made on the ribosome,
they have a bit of a choice.
They can get made
and fold beautifully
into active proteins.
Those proteins
could be modified.
They could go to different
places in the cell.
Occasionally, proteins misfold.
Maybe the rate of
synthesis is too fast,
or the environment isn't right.
So there will need to be
mechanisms whereby proteins
get degraded if they're
not folded properly,
but that's the story
for another day.
It's not always perfect,
but what is known now
is that, as proteins are
emerging from the ribosome,
they're starting to
fold almost immediately
from that N-terminus
to, ultimately,
attain their compact shape.
The last thing I
want to talk to you
about today is
what happens-- what
are the types of errors
we get in translation.
Now translation, like
transcription and regulation,
has some editing
mechanisms to fix errors,
but, occasionally, there
are errors in the DNA that
put different amino acids.
And the editing at that stage,
by the way, to fix errors
is editing when you've
loaded the wrong amino acid
onto a tRNA.
But what happens when the
DNA message, the DNA starting
point, is wrong, which means
the messenger is wrong,
which then means we get a
different translated proteins?
So I'm just going to give
you a couple of terms here.
When we have here-- and,
on all these slides,
I'm going to show you
the double-stranded DNA.
I'm going to show you the
messenger that gets made
and the protein
that comes forward.
And they're all lined up so you
can follow them really nicely,
always writing 5 prime
to 3 prime, except when
we have double-stranded
because we
have to put the bottom
strand in a different order.
First of all, this
entire chunk would
be called the reading frame.
It's the portion
of DNA that's going
to be read and transcribed
into the messenger RNA.
And, when you look
at the two strands,
you're going to have
to figure out which
one is the template strand.
And you would figure that out
by knowing that you read 3 prime
to 5 prime, but that you
transcribe 5 prime to 3 prime,
right?
So you could recognize
which of the two strands
you're going to make
the messenger out of.
Once you get the messenger,
you come straight
to the genetic code because
you can use the genetic code
to translate each of these.
Does that make sense?
So this would be
a situation where
you have a wild-type enzyme.
Everything is transcribed
and translated properly.
Occasionally, though,
there are errors
that will introduce defects
into the ultimate protein.
The first type of error
is a nonsense mutation,
which might be leaving
out a base pair,
inserting one, substituting one.
And this would,
ultimately, cause an error
in the DNA that then causes
an error in the messenger RNA.
So let's say we
delete by mistake,
or we're missing
the C-G base pair.
Then the messenger
RNA is now different.
And a lot of the base
pairs-- the bases slide up
to fill the gap.
So we have what's known
as a frame-shift mutation.
We've shifted things.
And what we've done by doing
that is introduce wrong codons.
So the first codon
was read properly.
The next one was read
properly, even though there
was a mistake, but then, all of
a sudden, we get in this mess
where one of the later
codons carries a mistake
and becomes a stop codon.
OK, does everybody see that?
So that would be called a
frame-shift mutation that
introduces a nonsense
mutation and puts a stop codon
into your messenger RNA, OK?
The next types of
mistakes are ones
that are what are
called silent mutations.
It doesn't matter, for
example, if you made an error
in the DNA, which ended up with
an error in the messenger RNA,
if you still code the
same amino acid, right?
I go to the genetic code.
I'm like, oh my goodness,
I've got a mutation.
Oh, it's fine.
CCC codes for proline, but
CCA also codes for proline.
So that's called a
silent mutation, OK?
Then the last ones
are the ones where
we start to encounter
errors in DNA that
result in errors in
proteins that may cause
genetically inherited diseases.
So let's take a look at that.
Here it's a missense
mutation where
we've got an error
in the DNA, which
has resulted in an error
in the messenger RNA.
So, instead of valine--
instead of leucine,
we've put in valine.
That's not so bad
because it's quite what
we would call conservative.
They're sort of
similar amino acids.
They have similar personalities.
So this is a missense
mutation, but it
doesn't cause any dramatic
changes, probably, in the DNA.
And then the last
one I want to show
you is a missense mutation
that is non-conservative
and causes a serious defect.
And this takes you back to
the beginning of the class
where we've put a
mistake in the sequence
where we've changed a
glycine to an arginine.
And that's a big change.
And I just want to remind you
of the situation in hemoglobin
when we had a missense mutation,
and we incorporated a valine
instead of a glutamic acid,
just through one change
in the DNA, which made one
change in the messenger, which
put a drastic change in the
protein that caused sickle cell
anemia.
So missense mutations
are where you
put in the wrong amino acids.
And those are the ones where
you end up, in a lot of cases,
with inherited diseases.
Nonsense mutations
are not so bad
because you probably just
truncate the protein.
You don't-- nonsense mutations
aren't so bad because you end
up with a truncated protein,
which would be degraded.
The missense mutations
are the more serious ones
because you end up with a
full length protein that
might have a mistake in it.
And then that would
affect the function.
Am I being clear
enough to everyone?
Yeah?
Good.
OK, I am going to tell you
that I'm handing over the baton
to my colleague,
Professor Martin.
He'll take over on Monday.
Mouse is pretty happy.
He's pretty excited
about genetics.
And these will be the
lectures that will occur.
What?
You haven't seen him, have you?
He's keen on genetics, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Great.
BARBARA IMPERIALI:
OK, and that's it.
Don't forget my office hours
on Monday if you need them.
I think this field
is fascinating.
Once you get used to
the mechanics of it,
it's really cool to think
of how you go from DNA
to RNA to folded proteins.